let's i i do want to at least talk about
a reason why you should vote against
democrats not that i think it's perfect
to vote for republicans but we have this
story from timcast.com amazon leadership
held a session to discuss matt walsh's
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus being problematic a customer said
that it's teaching kids to kill and
bully transgender people this is matt
walsh's book
this is amazon
being insane and going over the top now
i there's not much to say beyond this we
know amazon does this we know who they
are that's the news my point is the
reason why i would like to vote for a
republican is to get rid of this stuff i
want school boards to say look we don't
want critical practice in our schools
what does the left say republicans are
banning math
and this works because there are people
who just watch cnn
they believe it and then i'll respond
and say nobody banned math well what
about rhonda's betting math books he
banned math books that were filled with
critical praxis
i don't want books banned i want
curriculum of critical praxis and
christian praxis band because kids
should be taught two plus two equals
four moving on if the kid says i have a
question about mommies and daddies talk
to your parents about it if the kid says
i have a question about my spirituality
and my faith back talk to your parents
about it keep it out of the schools
practice i the implementation of the
ideology should be kept out if those are
the rules we're playing by i'm totally
fine with it
amen man
good story what we need is
more candidates
to step up and run for election
that believe in the things that you
believed him
that believe that crt
in the classroom is wrong we need more
people running like the parents in
loudoun county who challenge the school
board we need people to stand up and we
need people to show up to vote and
that's how you take the party back and
that's how you bring real change it
doesn't happen overnight it didn't
happen overnight for ronald reagan who
first made the speech in 1964
in support of barry goldwater it took 20
years
so it's it's uh i have no issue
if a school has a book on critical race
theory in the school i have no problem
if the school has a bible in the school
i have no problem the teachers say you
know if you go to the library you can
read the book i don't care we don't want
to ban those books you can read it you
can ask questions about it
my issue is with what's called praxis in
this instance it's not critical race
theory it's critical race applied
principles or critical race praxis the
left calls it critical race praxis
which is the implementation of the
ideology in other subjects an example
would be
writing a math problem that says
sheamus is a white male who is stopped
by police and frisked seven times per
year andre is a black man who has
stopped 247 times per year what
percentage of stops are so it's supposed
to be a math problem but they inject
critical race theory into it and that's
the praxis now we call it critical race
applied principles because that spells
crap and we don't want crap in our
schools um but no in all seriousness the
left doesn't call it critical race
praxis which is already three uh crp
which is crap basically well race has an
ra in it so you could just call it crap
as well
it's just funny how
pedantic we have to get about
distinguishing between these different
forms of left-wing thought which are
near identical as conservatives when
they just say everyone who disagrees
with them is a nazi and that's the one
label that they use
well the problem i think is
they lie all the time yeah and it works
yeah look at the story they then lie
about uh taylor loren is a great example
she went on cnn and said the right-wing
media lies
and it's fascinating because
that's projection that's always perfect
yeah right deny you know attack reverse
victim and offender it's them who's
lying you can only trust me it's people
like brian stelter who tells you not to
watch fox news
because he's guilty of that too
explaining that it's her job to tell you
what to think well that's our job and
then they denied it later then snopes
comes out and says that's not true it
never happened or or joe biden reaching
out to shake the hand of somebody that's
not there and then and snopes comes out
and says he never did it
or what was it what was it snopes i
think it was snopes he never actually
did it and it's like dude
you're fact-checking an opinion with
your own opinion yeah you're just lying
that's that's what they do it's the game
they play and then they come up with
something like the 1619 project the new
york times and they infuse our schools
with it which is an ideologically driven
fabrication of american history
especially the founding the founding
fathers the declaration of independence
the constitution was opposed to slavery
only two states and only two that's
right in the declaration the
declaration really did mean all men are
created equal two states opposed it
georgia and south carolina
you had to compromise at that time the
letters the history really tells you
that it really wasn't based upon
slavery or racism that there was really
a movement to move beyond that and
oppose slavery one of the original uh
grievances in the declaration of
independence was that the king had taken
people from their homeland brought them
there against their will and was using
them to wage war against them
they uh jefferson took that out because
the southern states that were
pro-slavery would not sign on so long as
the other colonists uh and leaders
opposed slavery now
they had slaves and it was bad
a lot of bad things happened many
countries still have slaves it's it's
really really bad
but
that that i think i don't know if that
was the uh the biggest mistake made or
but it was a big mistake because that
divide
that compromise it didn't end there
that that tacit agreement of look we'll
overlook this for now so we can win a
revolution and then 80 years later we're
in civil war
and now you know and then eight years
after that well world war ii but we'll
that's not domestic
you ended up with jim crow laws you
ended up with the clan you ended up with
this conflict that was just
seemingly never ending and if you look
back at everything we're dealing with
today it's all rooted going all the way
back to even before this the problem is
they need you to believe that the
founding fathers were evil so that they
can justify destroying american culture
because from the ashes of the old they
will build a new correct they want a
completely different system what they
want is a multicultural democracy people
need to understand when elizabeth warren
comes out and says this is dangerous for
our democracy and these democrats say
this they are not referring to your
country because you
goods are watching the show believe in a
constitutional republic not a democracy
and conservatives say you're wrong we're
not a democracy we're a constitutional
republic
no you don't you misunderstand they are
telling you
that there is a new multicultural
democracy growing in the united states
they're not making mistakes about it and
they're going after the symbolism they
want to invalidate the fourth of july
they want to deny its value and they
want to move to a june 19th type of
celebration that will overshadow the
july 4th celebration i do think it's odd
that we celebrate the introductions to
war so often like pearl harbor july 4th
what other days got us into war that we
celebrate i don't know but then 9 11 9
11 was another one but not celebrating
we don't well you could say we observe
we observe and or celebrate the fourth
of july is definitely a celebration why
don't we celebrate the day that the war
ended well good point but july february
right july veterans day is the only
example i could find and they changed
the name from armistice day celebrating
the end of the war to veterans day
celebrating the warriors themselves but
by the way we were at war for a year
before the declaration of independence
technically way longer than that
so uh
the the american war for independence
took 20 years
and a lot of these these moments i mean
they were going back 10 or so 20 years
before i think 10 or so years before the
signing of the declaration so the the
british regulars shooting people the
conflict the confiscations all that was
going on it just wasn't at the point of
people marching towards each other
i think that they celebrate the
inductions into war because it's war
propaganda they use it like remember
that we're the victim and we had to
fight i don't know that's how i that's
how i've been phrasing it so maybe
i don't know what's up with the june the
june 19th thing that you were talking
about what is that exactly that was the
day
that union soldiers made it to the uh
last place in the country in texas i
think it was gal was it galveston yeah
where uh the last slaves had not been
informed they were free men and finally
ended slavery okay so it's worth
celebrating as an end of slavery kind of
thing i don't think it has anything to
do with july 4th though i don't know why
those two would be in the same
conversation i i think june teeth is
cool i think i think like you know we
get a holiday in june to have barbecue
and celebrate freedom and independence
i'm totally for it slavery was abhorrent
and it took that long to get rid of it i
say we do another holiday and we
celebrate the end of slavery the real
end of slavery and we also have the
fourth of july when our founding fathers
set forth a new nation that was one of
the first at the time to challenge these
these monarchs these absolute
authorities and say of for and by the
people was it perfect no but it planted
these seeds and of the seeds planted we
were uh blessed with people like
frederick douglass
who challenged the american people to
uphold the words that they themselves
had put in their own constitution about
all men being created equal which
ultimately led to the abolition of
slavery and many other countries
retained slavery and still have slavery
to this day slavery was bad the fourth
of july declaration of independence the
constitution are all good things
juneteenth is also also a good thing i
will take two holidays absolutely
fantastic but also for whatever reason
we are a nation which doesn't want to
celebrate the fact that we ended slavery
we want to scold ourselves for the fact
that it ever happened even though
virtually every culture throughout all
of history has had some form of it and
we ended it well it's a political cudgel
but
the democrats wield it all the time but
if you go back and you know
louis gohmert did a good monologue on
that on the house floor
about the history of the democratic
party and slavery
they were the south the south in the
civil war
they were jim crow they were the kkk
they were the anti-sega they
reinstituted segregation under wood
woodrow wilson okay
segregated the government and the army
again
so
you know the democratic party
acts as though they are the defenders of
freedom and and of the slaves but they
were the ones behind it for
most of the american history and they're
also the party that just tried to repeal
the civil rights provisions from the
california constitution only a couple of
years ago yeah it's funny i was thinking
about this the other day they also argue
that there was a party switch and so the
democratic party can't be held
accountable or looked upon negatively
for the fact that they supported slavery
they supported jim crow etc
and yet
when you look at the nation as a whole
everyone is to blame right basically all
white americans are to blame to some
extent for slavery even though it ended
uh
the the history of it still remains but
then when you talk about the democratic
party oh well the legacy of that just
disappeared instantly right the party
switched and then the legacy of slavery
and racism within the democratic party
just vanished overnight and not not in
the country as a whole just in like the
pocket where it's convenient for us to
say disappear even though studies show
that white liberals dumb their language
down when they talk to black people
every it was it was actually this one
moment
where every single democrat like a
strike of lightning exactly just went i
was wrong
and the whole country changed it's true
yeah and every republican was hit
at once conversely by that same
lightnings
oh no
they've sent the racism to us
oh no they'll go oh
yes
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you